ici il y a que 10 mètres carrés on fera
jamais l'opportunité mais on estime que
les gens respectent notre qui est des
charges tu vois sa carrière aurait pu
être toute tracée en 2019
Oscar Lustin sort d'acc l'une des plus
prestigieuses écoles de commerce
françaises un poste l'attent chez Danone
avec un beau salaire à la clé mais
quelque chose lui manque je trouvais ça
plus compliqué on va dire dans un grand
groupe
d'apporter vraiment ma pierre à
l'édifice et que ce soit mesurable que
ce soit vraiment de A à Z je sois
convaincu que ce que je fasse au
quotidien et une utilité pour la société
pour l'environnement à 22 ans il décide
alors de se lancer dans l'économie
sociale et solidaire avec un ami de sa
promotion il monte domani une entreprise
qui crée des colocations pour personnes
âgées en perte d'autonomie dans la
région bordelaise on va voir ce que ça
donne
on essaie une autre couleur chaque
semaine il leur rend visite mais la main
à la pâte à presque 25 ans il gagne à
peine plus du SMIC un parcours bien
différent de celui de ses camarades HEC
pourtant Oscar Lustin ne renie rien de
ses études je suis pas totalement
rupture avec mon école parce qu'on a
quand même appris des choses qui nous
servent au quotidien pour monter des
projets viables sur le long terme donc
ça c'est important de pas on va dire
tout mettre dans le même panier et du
coup moi je me sens en rupture par
certains aspects avec la volonté de de
créer quelque chose de plus social et ça
il y avait pas trop dans les études les
écoles de commerce ce genre de choses
donc ça il y a une certaine forme de
rupture mais j'essaie quand même de
garder ce qu'on nous a appris parce que
ça ça nous permet ensuite d'avoir un
impact positif plus grand que si jamais
on n'avait pas fait ses études
Cécile Thibault elle aussi a choisi de
bifurquer
diplômée de Sciences Po Paris elle est
aujourd'hui maraîchère bio près de Liège
en Belgique là je suis en train de
récolter des blettes titulaires d'un
double cursus sciences politiques et
environnement elle n'a au départ que
quelques notions agricoles et choisit de
se former sur le tas dans des fermes
c'est un métier qui est hyper complexe
parce que
tu ben en fait si tu veux être
diversifié tu as une soixantaine de
légumes qui se comporte pas pareil
si tu en fait en fonction de la saison
autant dans des métiers de bureau
j'avais l'impression qu'à un moment on
avait fait le tour là ce qui est génial
effectivement en agricole c'est que je
pense que tu t'ennuieras jamais quoi
jamais jamais jamais et ben superbe
c'est fait Cécile Thibault a d'abord eu
un parcours plus classique chef de
projet chez Suez elle travaille sur
l'accès à l'eau potable le poste
l'intéresse mais elle cherche quelque
chose de plus opérationnel qu'elle
n'arrive pas à obtenir quand j'ai dit
j'aimerais bien avoir un poste
opérationnel travailler peut-être passer
en directeur d'usine parce qu'il y a des
petites usines en fait les stations
d'épuration c'est pas forcément très
grand ou directeur d'équipe réseau
on m'a dit mais voilà est-ce que tu es
sûr c'est un milieu très masculin la
production c'est l'usine bifurquer vers
l'agriculture n'a pas été une décision
difficile à prendre sa carrière a pris
un virage à 180 degrés et pourtant
Cécile Thibault n'a pas le sentiment
d'avoir fait un choix radical on peut
être un temps dans de la partie très
concrète très production et ensuite
aller peut-être travailler pour des
associations je pense qu'il faut des
deux en revanche je pense qu'il y a des
entreprises dans lequel il faut plus
travailler n'allons pas bosser comme on
est chez des gens dont l'organisation
est destiné
à ne pas aller vers bien commun
ça part au lavage
le maraîchage pour elle n'est pas une
quête de sens plutôt une expérience au
plus près du terrain et rien ne dit
qu'elle ne travaillera pas de nouveau un
jour dans un bureau à condition d'y
trouver un poste en accord avec ses
valeurs
[Musique]